when you did become an actress at a
young age because you started really
young did you feel that pressure that
you had to now bring in money to help
the family because you guys were so poor
I can't imagine what that's like I'm
glad that I learned to work hard early
and that I have like a work ethic that I
can rely on and discipline and that it's
expected of me like I think it served me
well to be somebody who cared about that
and also to be mindful about money and
not blown through it for ridiculous
things that don't add up you know I
don't need a I have a used station wagon
that's the my favorite car I've ever had
in my life it's a 1976. Jerry Seinfeld
must look at that car and go are you
really driving an old uh he wrote in it
with me for the very first time ever on
like an early edition of comedians
having coffee and cars he wrote in your
car the first time I ever drove it it
had just arrived from the middle of the
country and he was the first person in
the car with me and it's a beautiful
absolutely Exquisite boat you take the
subway a lot took it all day yesterday
this is crazy to me a Subway what are
you proving here
anything what are you doing look at
Google Maps and you put in your address
I'm missing 99 of the time the fastest
way to get there is the train it's just
petrified down there oh God no come
clean something bad must have happened
what is the worst thing you've seen in
the subway since you take the subway all
the time I mean what have you seen what
most people see who are regulars which
is people
going to the bathroom yes people
clipping their nails right people eating
people eating is barely an offense
anymore uh people you know Finding
pleasure that's right that way now what
happens when they see Sarah Jessica
Parker you're one of the most
recognizable faces on the planet I say
hi I have headphones on all the time and
say I'm so sorry I can't take a selfie
sometimes I'll say uh
they don't let they won't allow it who
and I'll say the government doesn't let
me take a picture and that's confounding
to people so that just is enough time to
move away I'm always really nice but I
tell them like I'm terrible at selfies I
don't take them well but what's your
name how are you or I'll tell them I'm
on a phone call I'm so sorry but nice to
meet you you know to be honest Matthew
and I got on you got on the one train
on Pride evening in the West Village
it was insane we were just trying to
walk from our house to the one train
it was absolute Madness but I was just
like let's just go to the middle of the
street let's just just put your head
down and I didn't have sunglasses I
didn't have any of my normal like
headphones sunglasses
and it was crazy
thank you